so far we've covered quite a few of the
important deity that make an appearance
in the Cthulhu Mythos but there is one
else I got in particular that many of
you have been requesting for quite a
long time so in today's video we will be
covering shub-niggurath also known as
the Black Goat in the woods of a
thousand young similar to many other
deities shub-niggurath is an entity
originally mentioned by Lovecraft but
only expanded on by the many authors and
contributors that followed she first
appeared in the story titled to the last
test in 1928 but remains a figure that
Lovecraft never really explained or
expanded on we do hear the name
mentioned in various rituals and
incantations but nearly all of her
description and law comes from August
Derleth Robert Bloch Ramsay Campbell and
many more of the mythos authors now as
to what Shabnam earth actually appears
as that's a bit harder to explain she's
essentially an enormous mass of horrid
proportion a cloud of black goo from
which emerges dozens of goat legs
hundreds of flailing black tentacles and
several mouths tripping of blood and
slime these mouse continuously spit out
small creatures and that is one of the
main reasons that she of Naga wrath is
regarded as a deity of fertility be it
far more grotesque than the deities of
fertility that we may be used to from
traditional mythology now as for the
origins of the name itself much of love
cross work was influenced by lord
dunsany
and it's likely that shub-niggurath is a
reference to a character in dunsany
streamers tales called shawl nuga north
who is also a date he associated of the
wild and untamed nature in terms of the
rather odd family tree that many have
attempted to piece together
shub-niggurath is one of the oldest
eighty's to exist as a thought of course
being the first and the oldest followed
by the nameless mist and it's sibling
the unnamed darkness shebna Groth is
considered a child of the darkness and
yorkshire sloth himself came from the
nameless mist so there are definitely
some parallels that we can draw there
considering that ship negraph was both
the mate and wife to yorkshire thought
making her one of the potential mothers
of Naga and yep and the grandmother to
our favourite squid boy the great
dreamer Cthulhu it's also believed that
she mated with the King in Yellow hosta
producing several different creatures
the most well-known being a thousand
young who also referred to as the dark
young in some cases now these children
are quite similar in description to
their mother they appear as a collection
of tentacles pitch black in color
capable of grown as big as 20 feet tall
standing on stumpy hoof legs like Ritesh
trees in a dying
forests the dark young often described
as abominations that smell like an open
grave and they can often be found in
woodlands wherever their mother's cult
has an active following in some cases a
dark young can act as an avatar or as a
mouthpiece for their mother
accepting the sacrifices from the cult
on her behalf there is one ritual that
can be found in the book of a bond that
summons a dark young through a blood
offering it states that the victim must
be sacrificed over a stone altar deep in
the woodlands at the darkest of the moon
the dark young would then manifest
devouring the offering intended for
their mother why these cults have no
direct interaction with shift McGrath
isn't really mentioned but it may have
something to do with the fact that we
don't really know where she currently
resides and haven't done so for some
time the most common theory being that
she's located deep beneath the surface
on the planet Edith yeah this was
originally a planet inhabited by the
knocks off but eventually they were
overwhelmed by race of huge worm-like
creatures called the dolls who
completely destroyed the knocks off in
their attempt to annihilate the planet
but sure McGrath was able to survive and
has been under the planet's surface ever
since
another interesting theory makes a
distinction between shivnath and the
black goat claiming that they're in fact
two separate entities the black goat is
described as a male figure being
referred to as the Lord of the woods in
the whisper in a darkness which is also
a title used to describe the Greek god
of the wild pan who himself as a deity
associated fertility this then led to
the theory that the black goat is
actually the personification of pan who
in turn is the earthly avatar of Shiva
niggath who breeds with her followers in
relation to who actually worshipped her
there are several groups that we can
take a look at these included the
Hyperborean z-- a race of mythical
human-like entities believed to have
originated from the far north in a lost
era the humans of the city saw Nath who
existed some ten thousand years ago also
said to be amongst her followers the MU
or the movie ins were primarily a race
known for their worship of katana Thor
the first born of Cthulhu but they did
have one member among them known as teok
who would eventually become a high
priestess Shipp niggath looking for her
assistance in destroying katana Thor and
its followers
she was also worshipped by a number of
alien species including the MIGO and the
Nagas earth
I know at times these lesser mentioned
the alien species can get a bit
confusing so I think I'll make a
follow-up video going over some of them
in some more detail one thing to note is
that many of her followers believe that
her milk mutated those who drank it into
terrible
so we do have this weird notion of her
followers seen this as the end goal
becoming one of her repulsive children
in cheb negraph we have another deity
created by Lovecraft who he himself
never really expanded upon it was
instead the writers who followed who
took the idea and implemented it in
their own stories some of the most
famous examples included Stephen King
who referenced her several times
including in his novel revival and then
again in his story Crouch End where we
see a woman being pursued by the minions
of the goat for a thousand young
eventually been hunted by the goat
itself towards the end of the story and
Terry Pratchett was also an author
well-known for taking the works of
Lovecraft and add in his own humorous
spin for example Pratchett has a
character in moving pictures called to
ship Alka Fett the infernal star toad
with a million young it was known to
kill its victims by showing them
pictures of his children until their
brains would explode there are dozens of
books TV shows mangas and games and in
some way referenced the character and
I'm sure many of you have fought against
shobhna growth as a boss in the latest
South Park game which of course has its
own rather comical approach to
Lovecraft's deities in terms of her
overall role in the mythos honestly I
don't really know and I suppose that's
how it's meant to be to me she fills the
role of the mother deity that we see in
so many other mythologies so perhaps she
is the dark twisted earth mother of
cosmic horror Limina what you think in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained